[Musique]
les chats sont dotés de multiples
qualités et surtout d'un don
extraordinaire il voit ce que vous ne
voyez pas
il voit même ce que vous auriez du mal à
imaginer
[Musique]
ils voient les elfes de maison
soulier les pierres n'est inventé en
comment t'appelles tu es jolie poupée
vous ressentez un grand bonheur vous
êtes chez vous tout est paisible et
rations
à partir d'aujourd'hui
c'est ici que vous voulez vivre vous
êtes heureuse apaisée votre vie va se
transformer en un conte de fées
[Musique]
one on regarde les lustres il touche
pourquoi tu ne veux pas de nous ici
c'est notre maison maintenant
elle de maison on était amis j'ai ma
famille et chez mon appartement chez moi
le patron vous fêtez votre départ alors
tu en a eu assez avoir une famille c'est
la chose la plus importante au monde et
tout est prêt à tout perdre
c'était quoi ça tu n'as pas encore
compris c'est sur mon territoire
tant que tu es en vie je suis très
heureuse que vous ayez accepté de me
débarrasser de lui je serai ton pire
cauchemar les élèves sont des êtres
gentil nous protégeons la maison
on s'est installé chez lui si tu
continues tu sais on fait du mal à ta
mère pour être heureux un elfe de maison
a besoin d'une famille aimante les
lèvres de la maison réveille toi et sept
au boulot il est temps de leur montrer
de quoi tu es capable
je dois tout faire dans cette maison